[Musica]
[Applauso]
quando ero piccola non me ne importava
nulla dello spazio
anzi a dire il vero mi faceva un po
paura a differenza degli altri bambini
che sognavano di fare gli astronauti
io avevo già ben chiari rischi ei
pericoli del mestiere
insomma non ci tenevo particolarmente
vedere una ispirata al gastrica giusti
nel mio stomaco o a dovermi sacrificare
perché distrugge con la nave aliena poi
ben mia mamma mi racconta che tutte le
volte che mi trovavo sotto un cielo
stellato facevo sempre tantissime
domande ma il mio interesse finiva lì a
11 anni infatti non avevo idea di che
cosa avrei fatto nella vita mi piaceva
alla natura gli animali le lingue
straniere pratica voci dinastica
artistica a livello agonistico
gli allenamenti che hanno sempre molto
dure al di fuori di scuola e palestra
non conoscevo altro
ecco se qualcuno fosse venuto a dirmi
che entro dieci anni visto che è
ritrovata a studiare e progettare i
motori degli aerei non ci avrei mai
creduto
se qualcuno mi avesse detto che entro
dieci anni avrei incontrato di persona a
tom hiddlestone l'attore che interpreta
il supercattivo dei fumetti e gli avrei
regalato una copia di un libro
interamente scritta da me probabilmente
chissà che in essa critica e se qualcuno
mi avesse detto che entro dieci anni
visto che ha ritrovato a inseguire il
sogno diventa gastronauta avrei detto
per favore impossibile già sono nata il
primo gennaio del 1999
questo significa che ogni anno sembra
che tutto il mondo festeggi il mio
compleanno insieme a me ma anche
significato che per tutta la vita sono
stata destinata a fare la primina ed
essere la più piccola di tutti i miei
compagni di classe
a causa di ciò sembra avuto qualche
difficoltà integrate nell'ambiente
scolastico tutti mi sono sempre sembrati
più grandi e più avanti di me
alcuni miei compagni addirittura mi
prendevano in giro per questo mi
dicevano primo gennaio
che sfiga per un giorno non potevi
essere come noi
a me è sempre sembrato un pò strano come
ragionamento ma solito e questo ha
contribuito a rendermi la ragazzina
timida e silenziosa in classe
all'inizio del liceo facevo schifo in
matematica non capivo la chimica e avevo
una memoria tremenda per le leggi della
fisica
il 20 i primi anni studiavo ma prendevo
quasi sempre voti insufficienti al primo
anno sono stata rimandata di latino
faticavo ad arrivare al 6 di matematica
in quel periodo mi sentii completamente
persa
studiavo ma non sapevo perché non avevo
uno scopo se non prendere buoni voti e
stavo fallendo poi un giorno e il
professore di fisica entri in classe ci
mostra qualcosa di diverso
scritto sulla lavagna un video
proveniente dalla stazione spaziale
internazionale mostrava la pittura di un
portellone da qui entrava una signora
fluttuante con i capelli corti scuri e
ci disse quella est amante cristoforetti
è appena arrivata sulla iss e della
prima donna italiana ad andare nello
spazio
la missione della cristoforetti fu la
prima che seguì da capo a fondo e
finalmente compresi che cosa
effettivamente significasse fa
gastronauta il che scoprì implicava
molti meno allievi di quanti a verso
immaginato mi appassionai in fretta di
ingegneria e astronautica perché insomma
l'idea di poter studiare e progettare
navi spaziali aveva dell'incredibile
così come l'idea di studiare e lavorare
duramente proprio come la ginnastica
artistica mi aveva insegnato per poi
arrivare nello spazio e sa che qualcosa
che nessuno ha mai fatto prima e fabbro
per la scienza
ho capito che quel lega la strada che
volevo prendere la prima cosa che mi
divenne subito chiara su che dovevo
sapere che tantissime cose dovevo
studiare moltissime andare davvero bene
a scuola avevo molto lavoro da fare ma
quello fu il mio punto di partenza e
durante gli anni del liceo non risolse
completamente le mie difficoltà con la
matematica e la fisica ma sicuramente in
pagaia ad agganciarmi da sola con ciò
che avevo
e un pizzico di logica testardaggine è
un po di passione per quelle materie poi
nel 2015 scoprì anche di avere coraggio
su una scoperta davvero sensazionale per
tutta la vita era stata etichettata come
la ragazzina timida silenziosa nascosta
nella propria comfort john ma alla fine
di dicembre del 2015
mi ritrovai da sola in un aeroporto ad
aspettare un gruppo di studenti polacchi
con cui avrei potuto comunica che
soltanto in inglese
eravamo direttiva che son che impasta
economico per il quale eravamo stati
selezionati tra centinaia di studenti e
dove hai studiato astronomia con ragazzi
dal cile dalla norvegia dalla spagna e
da tantissimi altri paesi del mondo
quello fu il momento in cui scopre di
avere coraggio e nel momento in cui li
trovai a festeggiare il capodanno e
quindi il mio compleanno
circondata da polacchi cominciai a
pensare che fox in fondo tutto fosse
possibile con quella stessa idea che
tutto fosse possibile nel 2016 partecipa
ad un concorso di ingegneria perché il
quale progettati da zero una base su
marte
avevo 17 anni e mi ritrovai esporre il
mio lavoro in inglese di fronte a una
giuria internazionale di esperti poi
accedere alle finali europee rappresenta
in italia con quella stessa idea che
tutto fosse possibile scrissi il mio
primo libro un romanzo di fantascienza
ambientato su marte è basato sui miei
studi indica i sei mesi a scriverlo
durante l'ultimo anno del liceo al
mattino andavo a scuola
al pomeriggio studiavo e la strega
scrivevo sapete cosa mi dicevano i miei
coetanei
mi dicevano ma tu sei pazza ma chi te lo
fa fare
lasciate che paga che tanto non ti
considera nessuno
la verità è che nessuno mi ha mai
obbligato a scrivere scrivere è sempre
stato il mio modo di esprimermi di
trasmettere attraverso la carpa quello
che provavo ogni spiegami immergervi in
quei personaggi che io stesso avevo
creato e non vedevo l'ora di scoprire
che cosa avrei fatto succedere ma avevo
18 anni ed erano veramente poche le
persone a supportarmi
mia mamma stessa mi diceva di smetterla
di pensare a studiare il libro si
intitola ad mag 12 l'ho pubblicato in
italia e poi all'estero dopo averlo
tradotti in inglese
da poco ho già pubblicato anche il
secondo nel frattempo entrai al
politecnico di torino perché studiare
ingegneria aerospaziale il grande sogno
che diventava realtà ma che ben presto
si trasforma in un incubo
fin dal primo giorno infatti mi resi
conto di non essere pronta la difficoltà
richiesta che è veramente alta e
nonostante credesse di avere superato
tutti i miei ostacoli gli che si conto
che la mia preparazione non era
sufficiente
ancora una volta è la più piccola tutti
erano più grandi di me gli sembravano
più avanti di noi come se non bastasse
il mio cane morì appena prima della
sessione è inevitabilmente non supera i
nemmeno un esame su un fallimento totale
avevo deluso tutti e anche me stessa era
stata una sconfitta totale ma d'altra
parte io non leggo mai nemmeno stata una
che avrebbe buttato tutto così come gli
anni del liceo mi avevano insegnato
trovai il coraggio di reagire e mi piace
rai fuori da quel periodo buio studiando
da tutte le risorse che riuscissi a
trovare e pian piano provando e
riprovando gli esami cominciavano ad
andare meglio
qualche volta scivola ancora ma continua
a provarci finchè non torna al livello
dei miei compagni
all'inizio del liceo facevo schifo in
matematica
adesso sono a metà del terzo anno di
ingegneria aerospaziale
ho pubblicato due romanzi quindi sì
esistono anche gli ingegneri senza barba
e con un lato umanistico sembra che la
barba nomi cresca studio il russo è il
cinese di recente sono stato nominato a
coordinatrice nazionale della mondi
legge su station un'associazione che
promuove le future missioni umane sulla
luna
nonostante tutto sono ancora all'inizio
del mio percorso è e so che cadrò altre
100.000 volte però incuriosisce sapere
che cosa succede se non mi arrendo
ho 21 anni
sto ancora inseguendo il mio sogno di
diventare astronauta ma che cosa
significa diventare astronauta per me ha
un significato ben preciso ossia a vega
e coraggio non importa quanto sia
difficile o improbabile sia liceo non
averti avuto il coraggio di seguire il
mio sogno forse avrei continuato a fare
il tifo in matematica
forse non avrei mai imparato le lingue
non avrei mai studiato molto e non avrei
mai scritto il mio primo libro ho 21
anni e non sento di avere abbastanza
esperienza per darvi lezioni di vita ma
se c'è qualcosa che nel mio piccolo ho
imparato è che vorrei condividere con
voi e di non aver paura di seguire il
proprio sogno
sono molte le persone che spesso mi
dicono di aver mollato di non aver
nemmeno cominciato semplicemente perché
il loro sogno sembrava troppo lontano
troppo difficile da raggiungere
quello che mi sento di dire è che se hai
un sogno
devi fare qualcosa anche se piccola
perché non sai mai dove potrebbe
portarti a 11 anni non mi sa che mai
sognato di alzare la mano in classe
perché parlare davanti a tutti se
qualcuno mi avesse detto che entro dieci
anni vista che katy cavata su un palco
di fronte a mille persone forse visto
che è nascosta sotto il banco grazie
[Applauso]